to understand how data science relates
to epidemiology
it helps to go back and look at jon snow
the first epidemiologist
jon snow was a physician in england and
he lived in the 1800s
and he was known for being the leader in
medical hygiene and also a leading
advocate for the use of anesthesia
which apparently up to that point was
not very common but
what jon snow is best known for is for
having responded to an outbreak of
cholera in london in 1854
and what he did was relatively unusual
he decided to chart the cases of cholera
on a map
he put a little mark where somebody has
developed cholera
if we zoom in on the middle part you can
see that right there in the center is
broad street and there is a lot of cases
next to one another on the south side of
the street
he was able to go to that location and
determine that there was a water pump
there and that people were getting
contaminated water from the water pump
he took the very practical step of
simply removing the pump handle from the
water
pump so people couldn't get water out of
it anymore and the cholera cases dropped
off dramatically
this is seen as the first step of modern
epidemiology
or studying the origins and patterns of
diseases
now we can do something a little more
advanced to that as opposed to simply
getting out some ink and putting marks
on a map
we can start looking at digital
information for patterns of disease
for example google was able to track the
spread of flu by looking at search
trends for symptoms related to the flu
another project by wikipedia did the
same thing except for more diseases and
more countries
similarly a third group of researchers
could predict a small but important
percentage of cases of pancreatic cancer
based on bing searches
interestingly all of those use people's
natural interactions with technology
and the internet to try to see what's
going on in their lives
but data science can do more than that
with epidemiology
one of the big tests of epidemiology is
estimating the prevalence of a disease
one research project has estimated the
levels of dengue in brazil from twitter
posts
what was interesting about that is they
were able to do it both at a very local
city level
and at a country level and they were
able to do it both in real time and
prospectively
other researchers developed an app for
the smartphone called flew near you
it asks people for flu symptoms they
report into it directly
and so that's going to the source
another very common source of data
is the seventy thousand people who use
the pro med mail mailing list
and this is a news aggregator it brings
together new stories
it brings together public health
announcements clinical observations
and that is considered a very high
resolution and a highly accurate source
of data that allows people to look at
outbreaks in one place or another
because people are specifically talking
about that in a professional environment
and then also another project has been
looking at the high resolution
or very high information and highly
detailed data that comes from medical
claims to identify medical claims in the
us as a way of tracking diseases by what
people are actually going to their
doctor to go see
all of these allow you to estimate the
prevalence of a disease either by using
naturally occurring data through twitter
posts
or getting more specific by asking the
people or by asking professionals
or even looking at the specific reports
of when people visit their health care
professionals
data science is also able to help
predict outbreaks of diseases which
allow you in turn to plan an
intervention
one interesting project has been looking
at gps data from phones
and that has permitted researchers to
track the geographical movement of
people who have been diagnosed with
ebola
these are people who they know have the
disease and they were able to see where
they are moving
and that allows them to design
interventions to hopefully contain the
risk of the disease spreading either by
encouraging the people not to move or by
preparing the new locations to deal with
the person who is carrying the disease
next other researchers have used remote
sensing in satellite images to gather
data about the physical environment
the animal movement and the human
interactions of groups of people to
estimate how many people live in places
that are known to have great risk for
the zika virus
this in turn allows you not to just see
how common it is in the patterns of
movement
but also to see what sorts of movements
and interactions create the greatest
risk
and also what can be done to help reduce
things proactively
finally one of these straight ahead data
science applications
is that researchers have been able to
take historical data about epidemics and
the spread and combine it with a diverse
range of data to create massive
simulations
these are very computationally intensive
to generate these simulations of
outbreaks
that allows them to estimate the
probability of various scenarios
and to design interventions that match
each of those scenarios
and their calculated probability
taken together data science allow you to
go from the very simple
but extraordinarily effective of putting
a dot on a piece of paper to find where
disease was
to looking at the natural traces of
twitter to asking people specifically
about their information
to even creating really advanced
simulations and all of them allow you to
estimate both the probability of disease
to find the sources to see how it
spreads through time
and hopefully to create interventions to
reduce the spread end
the risk of disease